are seeing the elite of the elite is
running foam up watch your hair on my
weight I cry like a giant gorilla Oh
[Music]
welcome to Baywatch just here for the
qualifiers one direction when is this
Lake guard hazing keeps dick you turned
the canals into the next game we were in
lifeguard pursuit oh okay except there's
no such thing as lifeguard pursuit night
night vision everything is better in
slow-mo
[Music]
the slow-mo running is one of the most
iconic things about Baywatch and we
couldn't wait to put it in our movies
ready guys
the iconic run is something that all of
us have been preparing for the entire
course of this film
so motion is an art watch and learn
[Music]
that's pretty good
no pressure what was it like doing the
quintessential slow-mo run lady's hair
right hair yeah yeah
and also that sort of determined look
that you have to get really determined
to save some money but in a very sexy
way I think it went great
laughs yes awesome
it was my idea with the director at
least what he's trying to make people
believe the key is just be cool just be
cool man
why does she look like she's running in
slo-mo the reason I believe in God
[Music]
you